personal finance is personal its
relational it has to do with people it
is not pure math math is only part of
the equation it is art and science it is
the art of human beings and wisdom
interspersed with mathematics when you
combine the two with wisdom you get an
accurate picture and you make wise
decisions when you make decisions on
personal finance based only on
relationships and completely ignore
mathematics you make a bad decision when
you make decisions based only on
mathematics and ignore the relational
implications of your stupid moves then
you're getting ready to discover what
stupid does it leaves a mark an example
of that is when you want to co-sign a
loan for your friend that's stupid
it says it in the Bible proverbs 1718
contemporary English version it is
stupid to co-sign a loan for someone
that's what it says in the Bible if you
don't like that version you could go to
the new King James it says one lacking
in sense son surety for another it's a
nicer way of saying it's stupid you know
why because lenders do nothing but lend
money asking a banker to loan you money
is like asking a dog if it's hungry of
course they want to loan you money no
doubt about it they want to loan you
money and if those people whose whole
reason for being the reason they think
God put them on the planet is to make
loans so that they can make their quota
and their boss smiles if they won't make
little junior a loan to buy a truck it's
because little Junior's not going to pay
the bill
and when you sign cosign with a little
junior you're gonna get bit dummy I know
this cuz it happened to me I was stupid
and I co-signed two loans and I ended up
paying them
one guy was stupid to co-sign the loan
for me when I went bankrupt he ended up
paying it I had to go back and pay him
back there's not any money and they went
after him it's stupid and he's a good
friend and he puts stress on our
relationship really put stress on his
wife she was not happy don't blame her
cuz she's looking at both of us going
you two guys are stupid
and she was right she was mad understand
went back and paid her back but she
still has always looked at listen when
you two are stupid you can't hang out
together when you're hanging out
together stupid stuff happens that's
relationships and when the Bible says
the borrower is slave to the lender that
is not optional that is a fact
and what that means is when you borrow
money from someone borrow money from
your friend you just changed the
relationship with your friend from
friendship to master/slave when you
borrow money from your mommy at no
interest because your mommy says that's
mathematically smart and deep down
inside your mommy has control issues
because she's still interfering in her
grown kids affairs but we're trying to
save on the interest and we're
mathematical geniuses but we ignore the
relational impact and the change in the
relationship from mother to grown son to
master/slave Thanksgiving dinner tastes
different when you eat with your master
my wife's daddy is one of the
we just most saintly men I've ever met
in my life and he loaned us a little
money when we went bankrupt to try to
keep the lights on in the house and it
changed our relationship he didn't ever
say a negative thing he never one time
but I felt different and I felt
different every time I walked into his
house every time I walked into his
presence until I got that loan paid you
can't keep that from happening it's not
optional and to ignore the wisdom of
that and say oh well it's mathematics
I'm getting free interest and everyone
should get all the free interests they
should get
let's go deeply in debt and stay there
forever because there's no interest
that's just stupid just dumb and I'm not
gonna argue with you about it if you
don't think that's the way it is then
don't call the show it's ok I'm not
gonna have an argument with you about it
this is the way it is don't loan your
children money for the down payment on
their first home these are gonna be the
parents of your grandchildren and you're
gonna change your relationship with them
until they get that stupid but second
mortgage that Mommy loaned them
daddy loaned them paid back don't do
that if you want to help your grown
children with money and you have some
money give it to them
I don't mind you giving them some money
as long as it's done in a healthy way
and there's no strings attached not
control freaking and all that kind of
thing give it to them but don't loan
people that you like money because you
change the relationship there's shame
there's control issues they look and go
where'd y'all go on vacation why you
still owe us money you went to Disney
World this is the kind of crap that
happens and it's not even subtle in most
families most families are just pretty
abusive to each other and others it's
just passive-aggressive in others it's
just one little eye roll that chills the
whole room
and changes the entire dinner party this
is personal finance boys and girls it's
also personal and if you don't accept
that you are being naive and unwise and
you're gonna cause problems in your life
so use some sense the old joke is if you
loan your brother-in-law $100 and he
never speaks to you again was it worth
the money
possibly depends on the brother-in-law
my case I got a good brother-in-law so I
wouldn't worry about it but oh but I
mean think about it does how many times
have you loaned somebody money just just
a friend at work your roommate you gave
him 50 bucks and they're gonna pay you
back on payday well then something
happens and then something happens and
then stuff happens and all of a sudden
you've messed up your friendship you
were trying to help but you didn't
understand this principle and the
principle is that you're a slave when
you borrow money even if your master is
a nice good master there's still your
master some masters are nicer than
others
my father in law very sweet man he put
nothing on me no I roles no condemnation
no control no nothing he never one time
said a negative thing it was all in my
head all in my spirit all in my busted
honor my integrity my brokenness from
having gone broke and I'm so trying to
take care of his daughter as her husband
and I can't and he has to step in see
all of that's mixed up in this horrible
little gumbo down inside your spirit
right bad stuff y'all and this is how
life works and again that that's all on
me is a hundred percent my fault but all
it was was I did not accept the truth of
these principles the wisdom of these
principles
and so don't loan your children money
even if it's interest-free don't loan
money to anyone unless you want to cause
problems in the relationship and only a
fool cosines don't be a fool
bad stuff happens to fools I've been a
fool it leaves a mark don't do that
[Music]